c'est parti trois descendants un truc
d'horreur est ce que vous savez que
celle ci n'est bloqué vous faites avec
la beaucoup plus car l'immeuble le
factice
non
ça ne se voit pas d'accord là il ya une
semaine était ouverte effectivement
l'emploi cas des grilles pour moi c'est
très bien fait j'ai l'impression que
c'est un immeuble normale après ça et
maintenant vous me dites qu'on regarde
les fêtes on voit que que tu ton à un
mur à un mètre des fêtes
ces lots à tous ces winterstein pour
brut et aujourd'hui je me retrouve sur
les toits de pareilles dumas faty se
trouve juste de l'autre côté du coup le
projet tata est dedans jusqu'au fond
c'est parti on va s'engouffrer dans la
dce métalys sent bien le vent ici on
nickel l'action voilà
bon et juste pour la forme vous allez
voir dehors c'est l'étrange
pas facile
voir si c'est long et froid
lâchée au niveau de la rue et nous on va
aller de plus en plus bas
les meilleurs il
condescendant un truc d'horreur
on soupçonne qu'ils aient quantités
astronomiques de polluants des
particules qui en sortent et qui
polluent finalement kivu voisinage aux
alentours et une très mauvaise qualité
de l'air intérieur dans ces enceintes
souterraines notamment à cause d'un
manque de ventilation et parce que le
système de freinage sont très émetteurs
de particules chine vous pouvez
l'imaginer c'est finalement derrière ces
petits meubles un peu factice
on est derrière une grande cheminée qui
rejette beaucoup de polluants et l'a
finalement on s'en rend pas compte parce
qu'on a cet immeuble et c'est une sorte
de tromperie
mais si on avait passé des immeubles est
factice et pour envoyer finalement pour
grande cheminée devant nos yeux
là il y aurait plus grande inquiétude et
surtout y arrivera les gens qui habitent
à côté
demanderez à ce qu'on leur rende des
comptes
[Musique]
la turquie aussi en quarts et 55
on va tester à deux points près
m
je suis juste au dessus de la bouche
d'aération et du coup je mets aurait ici
au haut niveau du toit quand ça se passe
on à 77
[Musique]
ça se serait mise un peu quoi
quand je prenais la mesure en bas et je
sentais les vibrations du métro donc
c'est alors qu'ils passent encore les
mesures en fait s'élever à ce moment là
donc voilà ça arrivait jusqu'à 60-70
alors qu'avant c'était
dans les environs des 58 sahraouis
camions et pick associé au suisse sur
les toits c'est une moyenne de 70 et un
chiffre de 70 ça correspond à quoi merci
c'est mauvais voilà c'est encore pire
que les solvants table de piles de
pollution s'est très
[Musique]
où
il est très dangereux c'est que comme
c'est une grande bouche d'aération ça
crache de l'air donc c'est beaucoup
d'air qui est rejeté et qui donc se
disperse en plus encore plus aux
alentours et dans le voisinage
là on va faire une mesure de pollution
de l'air dans la rue d'autres dans l'air
extérieur aux conditions extérieures
on tourne autour et à 2,23 microgrammes
par mètre cube
donc on respecte la norme européenne
mais par contre on ne respecte pas les
recommandations de l'om est ce qu'ils
disent que pour avoir un air sain on
doit être avant